the something strange in the
neighborhood and it's not the thing
everybody's talking about the upcoming
Ghostbusters film which is currently in
production something that I have debated
about weighing in on for a while a
little bit of context the original
Ghostbusters is my all-time favorite
movie I do recognize that to a certain
degree that is nostalgia but I will
argue the merits of this movie to anyone
until my dying day all that having been
said I am NOT looking forward to the new
Ghostbusters film now a big part of why
I have not talked about this project up
until this point is that the
conversation has been pretty much
dominated by the fact that the new one
has an all-female cast the people
complaining about that and the backlash
against those complaints that's all
anybody has been talking about and I did
not want my input on this project just
to be labeled with you're just mad cuz
its girls now and honestly that might
still happen but I'm hoping that we're
far enough along in terms of this
overall thing and in terms of talking
about it then I can voice my concerns
and why I do am NOT looking forward to
this and why I'm nervous and not have it
just get tossed aside with that same
group ultimately for me the problem
comes down to one huge issue which is
why is this a reboot again I need to
stress this very strongly I do not have
a problem with the fact that it's not
the original cast nor do I have a
problem with the new cast being of a
different gender but I do have a problem
with the old Ghostbusters universe which
is a very well-established one at this
point being completely wiped clean when
I have yet to hear a truly viable or
valid reason for doing that why should
two films two cartoon series a bunch of
comic books and just the general pop
culture absorption of what Ghostbusters
is suddenly not count anymore that's the
most first I should know what I think
are generally the reasons that are valid
for why you would reboot a property the
first reason would be if the current
series that you've got is simply too
tainted this is kind of the Batman of
Robins scenario now that film left such
a bad taste in everybody's mouth that
really the only way to move forward with
bad
on film was to wipe that away and start
from scratch now as much as I personally
may not care what the second
Ghostbusters film I don't think that's
the case here and I don't think you can
argue that it is there's still a very
great and very strong love for these
characters I mean that's why this movies
happening at all now another reason to
reboot a franchise is the age of the
actors and this would think of say the
Star Trek reboot that was a case the
actors where they were too old to keep
going the only way to move forward is to
start over and get young people to
embody these characters so that you can
basically restart the timeline again
again that's also really not the case
here I mean up until Harold Ramis dying
this was going to be a sequel now yes I
understand he's dead and the actors are
older but just look at the fact that
we're not actually dealing with the same
characters we're dealing with the same
concept on a whole new set of characters
now it may actually turn out that each
of these female characters is an analog
for one of the pre-existing male
ghostbusters but even if that is the
case of just rebuilding off the
archetype they're not really rebooting
the characters and doing that sort of
younger reboot for our characters is
really only necessary if the characters
themselves are absolutely intrinsic to
the central concept and it cannot move
forward without those same characters
and again obviously that's not the case
we have a whole new set of characters
here another reason to reboot a
franchise is if you want to take it in a
direction that the existing material
simply does not allow you to go in maybe
you've got new ideas that just
inherently go against the Canon of
established film so far maybe the tone
is just not is not in keeping with what
has happened before this will kind of be
like the Casino Royale example I mean
James Bond had been recast several times
up to that point and none of those have
really been a reboot but this was a case
where they wanted to go back tell a
story of his first mission but not have
it be a period be set in the 60s so that
was the reason for that reboot what they
wanted to do could not be done with the
existing timeline a story that had been
established now while we don't really
know all the ins and outs of the story
that's gonna be told in this new
Ghostbusters everything that's been
talked about with the people behind it
has been very emphatically saying that
the tone is going to be the same as in
the previous film so again no need for a
reboot there finally the last
reason to reboot is when a film is an
adaptation of an existing property that
you can make the argument that the
reboot is being truer to the source
material or maybe is gonna emphasize
aspect of the source material that were
not done in the previous adaptation
again James Bond kind of falls under
this a little bit but again that does
not apply to ghostbusters because this
was a film first this was not an
adaptation of existing material there's
been a franchise worth of material since
then but it was always a film first now
coming back to what I said before about
the fact that we don't know a ton about
this story but even with as little as we
know I don't feel that having an entire
new team of ghostbusters is enough to
justify a reboot unto itself I mean why
can't they just be the next generation
of ghostbusters why can't they just be a
separate franchise of ghostbusters I
mean Dan Aykroyd's original concept of
the thing was actually that they would
be very much like firemen and there will
be fire stations and new stations of
ghostbusters all over the city all over
the country so why can't this just be a
different group hey you can even keep
the fact that they're gonna make their
own gear it got established and
ghostbusters 2 that supernatural
activity waxes and wanes I mean at the
start of ghostbusters 2 things have been
completely quiet to the point that the
Ghostbusters basically had been out of
business for the past few years now I
actually don't think that was a
particularly good idea story wise in
ghostbusters 2 but now that that already
has been established it's not perfectly
reasonable that the original
Ghostbusters would have retired and that
this is a new group coming up and maybe
this new group is making their own stuff
they're on proton packs and so forth
based off of maybe older broken-down
models are just what they understand the
original Ghostbusters were using and
that idea what actually even worked
really well with the shots that we've
seen that have been released of the
proton packs and of ecto-1 and so forth
it's all very much strongly the
aesthetic of the original films but it's
not quite exactly that I mean really it
looks like what someone who maybe had a
blueprint of a proton pack but not the
actual thing itself would have put
together and if they were doing this
instead of rebooting the use of the
exact same logo would actually
makes sense because they just be repro
creating it for this new generation of
this new franchise of ghostbusters
as opposed to having it be a completely
different continuity but they just
coincidentally happen to use the exact
same logo
I'm pretty sure they're even bringing
back Slimer whose iconic as heck but is
in no way vital to the storytelling
there's all this emphasis whenever the
director talks and whenever they release
these publicity stills that look see
it's just like you remembered but if
it's just like I remember why are you
rebooting it why are we ignoring all the
stuff that came before
generally the point of a reboot as I've
laid out is to go it with a new
direction do something different but
you're not you're emphasizing how much
it's the same look the only way that I
can think of that the story might demand
that this thing be rebooted is it there
completely restructuring the rules and
the way that ghosts and the technology
function but I honestly can't even bring
myself to believe that that's gonna be
the case because the rules were so
loosely defined in the first place that
if you just overlaid the correct techno
jargon over it you can do anything you
want
look I am just really infuriated that
it's a reboot and they're getting rid of
the old stuff because there's nothing
that I have seen about any aspect of
this that justifies throwing out the old
continuity in fact I find myself keep
thinking if they were keeping the old
stuff it would save a whole bunch of
time now instead they're gonna have to
dedicate screen time to explaining the
ghosts the traps the proton packs when
by all indications they're not doing
anything new or different with any of
those things again let me stress I don't
care that it's a new team I love the old
team but I don't need them to be enemies
even before Harold Ramis died I didn't
need to see them old running around
chasing ghosts I mean Indiana Jones for
kind of proved to me that that's not a
good idea I don't care that it's a team
of women and just having a new team it
doesn't require anything in terms of
race or gender you can go any direction
with it I don't care that Chris
Hemsworth is the secretary Hey
I heard that that was the first bit of
news about this movie that actually kind
of made me smile because I thought
that's kind of funny as a concept I
don't need the exact version of
ghostbusters that I grew up with to be
put up on skirt on screen for my own
nostalgic purposes I honestly would
rather it would just leave the franchise
alone all together but what I really
haven't heard is a single reason for why
my version and my film that I love
shouldn't count anymore I haven't heard
the argument I know that the old movie
doesn't suddenly go away and it doesn't
exist but it's still kind of sweeping it
under the rug going yeah we're not gonna
talk about that anymore
and I could deal with that and I would
not be so frustrated and so exasperated
if somebody anybody give me a reason a
necessary reason why this is a reboot
and not a continuation cuz I haven't
heard it and until I hear it I can't
possibly get excited about a new
Ghostbusters so that's it that's my
argument do you think there is a reason
to be rebooting this instead of having
it just be continuation with a new team
if you do believe there was a reason
please share something down in the
comments and let's talk about it but
until next time this council is
adjourned